I'm sure that everyone now has watched
Game of Thrones
I watched it was very tough for me hey
was tough for everyone I mean I won't
give any spoilers out but I think by now
everyone knows that the episode is so
dark from the start of the episode it's
pitch black and I go okay it'll get
better it'll be five minutes ten minutes
fifteen a full Haiti two minutes I
couldn't see anything you didn't know
what was happening I don't know what
happened you didn't see one of those
zombie dudes fighting like you couldn't
tell who was fighting you never saw an
individual zombie dude I still don't
even know what happened that kid who
sits in the wheelchair I don't know what
he was doing I had to go on these stupid
websites with the the nerdy people who
actually slow it down and look frame by
frame to find out what happened you
don't have to call us nerdy people and
here's a weird thing everyone around
here who works with us was complaining
about the episode John Hind thinks it
was like the greatest oh and he's weirdo
like he's the guy who started jumped the
shark and I said John you know it I used
to think you were really bright guy and
I really he just jump good yeah a good
critic like he's in here defending it
you got to hear him you want to hear
John you have no idea what happened when
you were watching it you probably had a
read blog the blog oh I read those
anyway after the fact but no I liked the
episode a lot how how could but you
couldn't see anything this fight was
supposed to take place at night right in
the north
yeah you know so I think what they tried
to do and I admit it was dark but they
tried to make you feel like a part of
them no need to be part of it but let me
ask you something why I listen when I
saw know who's getting killed when I saw
the Helen Keller story on film she's
blind I don't need to be blind
why have you Helen Keller's point of
view no don't you want to see the zombie
fight the other person don't you want to
see what they look like did you could
see the zombies look I'm not gonna speed
you see whines ah yes
you saw more than one no you saw me did
not you only saw the loser really there
was a really tall guy who came in right
yeah
but that was I couldn't even see the
battle that was a great scene you can't
tell me but you weren't sitting there
for the first hour scratching your head
going what the [ __ ] are they do I wasn't
my TV in a movie you want to see I was
screaming - oh come on John you couldn't
you love that show so much you can't
[ __ ] get off this you're a guy who I
had credibility with me I'll see a whole
different life I'm not saying it wasn't
dark
I admit III echo wasn't look at me with
honest an honest look okay you loved the
episode yes you loved it yes one of your
favorites I thought it was great
that big woman that did Oh Brianne yeah
the one who is just a knight yeah okay I
don't know what now all right
I'll tell you how you know you went on a
blog no you see Gary what do you make of
it oh boy you swallow your food and then
tone it's probably the biggest
disagreement we've had since I've known
him Anne and I we were having the same
argument he's like no you're wrong
they're trying to recreate recreate the
confusion of war I'm like I don't want
to be confused I want to see the [ __ ]
war know the confusion of war can be
seen but you got to be seeing it was
confusion in Saving Private Ryan JD do
you agree with him Thank You JD do you
really like that I do admit it was dark
and some things were confusing this like
when the dragons are flying around but
overall I understood what was happening
are you drug 'el to understand that why
should you have to struggle why should
it be a struggle
I wanted to see dragons I wanted to see
the army I saw another giant mass of
zombies who it was it was black thank
you John for your hobbies it's hard to
thank
theme song hit victim with our pie